faire ce que vous ne pouvez pas faire
mais qu'est ce que cela peut bien
vouloir dire puisque jeudi envoyant
l'annnonce de ce nouveau et d'excitant
faire une chose qui est impossible en
théorie en théorie car si je la fais et
donc de manière pratique réalisable on
parle donc d'une chose qui n'est pas la
représentation mentale que je me fais
elle me semble inatteignable
inatteignable ça parce que j'ai jugé que
départ mes capacités n'est pas mon
environnement ou deux par des
contraintes que cela elle d'exiger cela
m'était impossible
ces pauses avoir la question de savoir
comment j'ai abouti à cette conclusion
et pourquoi voit la fin d'un possible
puisque c'est impossible
et surtout comment faire l'impossible
alors j'ai longuement réfléchi et me
semble beaucoup du parti n'en de vous
parler d'une histoire à raconter une
histoire d'un ami qui lui a fait
l'impossible c'est amis s'appellent
jacques jacques vit dans une famille
assez compliqué il a bien sûr une mère
un père une soeur et deux demi frères
elle est tellement compliquée cette
famille qui me faut la contextualiser
bon apport du père le père vient d'avoir
son diplôme on met des finances tant
bien que mal pendant que mal non pas
parce qu'il est bête
d'ailleurs s'avère qu'il est surdoué
mais parce que il eut dès la plus tendre
enfance des problèmes en effet été fils
de classe ouvrière d'étrangers parlais
pas la langue du pays et ses parents le
maltraitait et nous nous voulait tout
moment pas que celui ci fasse des études
il a bien compris que pour s'émanciper
des six classes sociales il fallait en
faire et une fois son diplôme en poche
il voulu comme tout le monde
trouver un travail malheureusement ils
avaient tellement souffert et des
connaissances en ne connaissant pas les
noms de ces deux classes sociales
supérieures qui s'offrait à lui il n'est
plus adapté et décida alors de se
reconvertir dans deux métiers la
sécurité la sécurité car le danger la
stabilité et la malveillance était de
mise et cela correspondait beaucoup
rien ne se perd malheureusement la tante
de jacques liban autant de chance en
effet est en bas dans une longue
dépression dès l'âge de 15 ans et connu
par la suite quelques troubles
psychologiques
or maintenant de la mer la mer est une
fille et de politiques étrangers qui
durent faire la guerre malheureusement
le grand père de jacques mouvaux pays et
la grand-mère mouvaux quelques années
plus tard en france une leucémie
ainsi cette mère vu d'autre choix que de
se faire élevé par ses phares et soeurs
qui n'était guère de beaucoup ses aînés
puis ensuite à un contrat un homme avec
qui est lu et deux demi frères
le kit à puis rencontre à un autre homme
et qui bien sûr a eu jacques et sa soeur
charlotte
malheureusement le l'entente entre le
père et deux demi frères se dégrader de
jour en jour à tel point que la justice
du cemi c'est au sein de ces deux
familles et décida alors de séparer les
deux demi frères et des envoyé chars
vrai père pour plus de sécurité
la mer était dépité sa chair son sens
ses deux aînés allait partir de la
maison et cela n ai plus jamais lui
pardonner à ce père le père de jacques
voilà une nouvelle histoire de famille
créer ou une deuxième si on me parle des
grands parents bien sûr
ainsi jacques et sa soeur furent élevés
sans en deux demi frères
je suis arrivé dans une cité hlm dab
rues parisiennes
même si t as chez nous le père grandi et
où l'italie lui même délinquant étant
jeune d'ailleurs encore un délinquant il
ya la délinquance en cécité pour ajouter
également bon certains voisins sont
également deux dealers ça se fait à 10
ans il ya également les contextes de
cécité les bâtiments vétustes pas les
raisonnements acoustique pas d'isolement
thermique dégradation à célébrités et à
cela s'ajoute un nouveau problème
familial l'épreuve de l'argent en effet
les parents se disputer beaucoup de
l'argent même devant les enfants
heureusement il y aura inventé d'esprit
d'enseigner des vraies valeurs
une vraie éducation et où trouver les
solutions aux problèmes alors est paru à
jacques évident qu'il fallait faire
comme papa et prend l'ascenseur social
qui étaient les études
mais ce ne fut pas chose facile en effet
il y avait déjà un problème avec la
langue
il appelait pas l'état il ya des
difficultés à apprendre à lire et avait
des gros problèmes de concentration mais
malgré cela il fit de son mieux et aller
très bonne note
ainsi il peut demander un collège dans
la ville voisine qui était plus riches
et donc un vrai jeu plus prestigieux
alors les parents et je vais avec
lui-même était fier puisqu'il avait
commencé sa première émancipation
quitter cet environnement de citer
quitter ces gens qui côtoient et tout le
temps et que peut-être il aurait dû
côtoyer au collège les propos les plus
chanceux au lycée il faut arriver à la
barre tout content choc des cultures des
enfants certes mais un peu différent
avec des vêtements de marque des fils de
parents rézé avec des loisirs différents
et donc des intérêts différents
mais jacques l'on n'avait que faire
puisque tu es content mais commencent à
s'émanciper comme papa vint alors la fin
du premier trimestre de sixième il
obtient la note de 12,12 moyenne n'était
pas content cela ne correspondait pas à
son niveau d'après lui il voulait
montrer à lui-même et à tous ses autres
enfants d'une classe sociale autre que
la sienne que lui aussi était bon alors
il décide à travailler encore plus enfin
6e
il obtient la note de 14 on était
content 5e 25e lottin l'allemagne de 15
ans 4e il passé de 15 à 17 de moyenne
lors qu'ils étaient contents de ces
progressions lui qui avait fait tant de
chemin pour arriver là malheureusement
il avait un autre problème
après une physique disons en effet ils
étaient obèses et quand vous savez les
gens en collège les enfants au collège
laissant guère tendre avec des gens
ayant des différence différence physique
où les différences sociales
ainsi ils subissaient quelques aux
discriminations mais bon et que faire il
était là pour s'émanciper
le reste n'est qu'un détail entre temps
le père de jacques
trouvera du travail en irak toujours
dans sécurité jack n'était pas content
déjà qu'il ne voyait pas souvent son
père à cause du travail
il a des manants risqué sa vie pour trou
pour amener de l'argent et ça ils
avaient bien compris l'argent qui était
la raison des disputes quotidiennes des
parents alors j'ai finalement accepté ce
fait alors entre temps et décida alors
de maigrir et d'essence et de s'enlever
cette étiquette de gros porc qu'on
l'aimait lui m étant enfant et il
réussit car c'est un docteur est arrivé
en 3e le pardon et le père jack décida
de changer de vie de changer de pays non
pas pour le travailler mais juste pour
changer une culture de vie alors il
partir tous en uruguay
alors il va d'abord jacques était
content il quittait cette situation de
cité hlm et ces termes est arrivé au
lycée français de montevideo
alors comme jacques avait eu des bonnes
notes en troisième ils pu sauter la
troisième veut pas passer le brevet est
arrivé un crime est en retard en seconde
un nouveau défi pour un si petit garçon
lui qui devait maintenant rattraper un
retard d'un an de troisième et un
trimestre et apprend une nouvelle longue
et ben on était motivés et réussi à
atteindre la tête de classe en fin
d'année entre temps jacques avait
réfléchi à un métier un métier dans
lequel il devait s'émanciper ingénieur
en génie civil
malheureusement quelques mois plus tard
le père fils fériés temps libre le web
et non plus assez d'argent pour financer
les études de ses enfants est dû les
retirer de ce lycée français et les
maîtres au cned par le cned vous
explique c'est très simple c'est d'un
organisme scolaire qui vous fournit les
livres avec lesquels vous devez étudier
puis il n'ya pas professeur pour vous
expliquer bien sûr il y en a mais quand
c'est l'été en france c'est l'hiver en
uruguay et donc forcément les enfants
n'ont pu non plus avoir recours à
certaines ainsi jacques était dépité il
allait devoir apprendre tout seul les
cours il y voyait plus ses amis
forcément pas voilà plus de travail
c'est monde s'écroule autour de lui mais
comment vais-je faire pour atteindre ce
rêve
le devenir ingénieur avec toute cette
situation mais c'est pourtant une
question peut-être la plus importante
qui d'autre que moi peut m'aider la
réponse est immédiate
personne alors finalement ils se
motivent à s'est il se dit bon je vais
étudier on va essayer on sait jamais
façons il n'y a que ça à faire et voilà
le pourquoi de vouloir faire
l'impossible il y avait un but
il y avait un rêve s'émanciper
l'impossible était tout bonnement ce
monde qui s'écroulaient sous ses pieds
et il voulait quand même essayer puisque
toutes façons il n'y a que fait ça que
cela à faire maintenant je vous parlais
des comment il a fait le père n'ayant
plus assez d'argent décida alors de
retourner en europe
la mère partie à paris rejoindre sa
soeur et le père et deux enfants partir
chez les grands-parents en italie les
grands-parents qui souvenez vous
maltraitez le père quand il était jeune
et qui avait autant plus une bonne
raison d'aimer frisé encore une fois
puisqu'il venait une main devant une
main derrière ce père était sous
pression
en effet il n'est pas sa femme à côté
mais plus de travail il a enlevé ses
enfants de l'école mais sait pas quel
avenir les un temps et peut-être en sa
faute il revient chez ses parents avec
qui il s'entend pas très bien il ya sa
soeur qui vit également cette maison et
qui est malade
bref tellement sous pression qui se
disputait souvent avec jacques
mais jacques avait bien compris que ce
père était sous pression et que du coup
c'est normal qu'ils se disputaient avec
lui ainsi il subissait
heureusement qu'il y avait sa soeur à
sölden la seule confidente
mais un jour sa soeur en eu marre de ces
situations
ce contexte explosif de tension qui
régnait chez les grands parents
ainsi elle demanda à son compère parti
rejoindre sa mère à paris
il accepta jack était malheureux la
seule jeune sa soeur allait partir mais
bon c'était pour son bien alors il dit
au revoir avec un grand sourire et
maintenant était seul seul face aux
remparts face à son père face au
problème est bon il fallait bien devenir
un homme comme on dit
ainsi décidé de travailler encore plus
pour ici pour essayer de réussir malgré
ces situations puis vint la fin de
première de première s briquet 15 des
généraux les payer un billet d'avion
pour aller en uruguay passer son bac de
français histoire géo puis revint en
italie et quelques mois plus tard il
obtint les notes des français
histoire-géo 13 13 à l'écrit de français
19 alors le français et 19 en
histoire-géo incroyable jacques malgré
qu'ils n'avaient pas le professeur marie
ce contexte il avait réussi à étudier et
le ici peut-être à toucher du doigt
c'est impossible
c'était mon psy passion qui voulait
alors il sait motiver encore plus pour
essayer de de l'attraper c'est
impossible
ce rêve ainsi il continue à étudier et
entre temps le père avait trouvé un
travail congo c'est laisse à son fils
tout seul harrigan par jacques tout seul
depuis restée pas plus qu'un mois et
demanda alors de partir rejoindre sa
mère qui n'est pas vue depuis neuf mois
et sa soeur qui n'avait pas vu depuis
sept mois
il va là bas était content n'y voyez sa
mère sa soeur sa mère avait trouvé
d'ailleurs du travail à l'idéal il
fallait bien trouver un de l'argent pour
se nourrir petite anecdote est le
laisser dormir dans son lit et dans les
parterres tous les jours du coup en
effet ils devaient tous chez la tante de
jacques qui avaient déjà une famille de
cinq personnes et en qui en plus
accueillir trois personnes dans le
besoin
heureusement ainsi les jours passaient
et la mère de jacques se dit un jour se
disputa avec sa soeur la soeur de la
mère ainsi il se disputèrent tellement
fort fortement que cette tendance les
jeter dehors est vrai maintenant à la
rue roy qui était député
encore un problème encore un nouveau
mais heureusement vous sépare les
détails la main de jacques trouva un
appartement dans le même d'un même site
et qu'au départ et le père revint alors
vivre avec eux puis vint un terminal s
en six mois trois mois de séances
travaux prouvent les autres matières
déjà qu'on partie en uruguay au passé le
vrai bac stressé comme tous les enfants
bien sûr
vous savez pas s'il réussit il savait
pas s'il allait avoir 10 puis 20
décembre 2014 les résultats alors son
d'examen stressé chercheurs son nom
jacques mon sens très bien
incroyable il avait réussi encore une
fois mais cette fois ci pour de bon de
réussir ses études
maintenant ils allaient pouvoir demander
une très bonne prépa pour devenir
ingénieur
il demande à l'un des meilleurs d une
des meilleures prépas de france lycée
pasteur de neuilly sur seine à l'oreille
tu attends décembre à septembre pour la
rentrée et c'est le tendre la diligence
enfin ils allaient pouvoir voir des
jeunes se sociabiliser lui qui a été
privée pendant trois ans de ces sociétés
de cette jeunesse
alors au début était plus ils étaient
plus occupés à se stabiliser
car à écouter les cours mais comme vous
le savez en prépare c'est déjà le river
déjà assez accéléré pour quelqu'un qui
vient du lycée après quelqu'un qui m'a
du cned je vous laisse imaginer
de plus certains professeurs avaient
déjà jugé que de par le papier vide au
cned sa possible de réussir en prépa
mais marek on le condamne à jacques été
déterminée alors il étudia de 8 heures
jusqu'à 23 heures tous les jours même le
samedi
même le dimanche s'ajoutent à cela les
contacts de la cité et disputes
régulières de ses parts et s'immiscer
dans ces disputes là puisque c'était la
seule chose sa famille qui permettait
d'aller plus loin
la seule chose qui était pérenne est
sûre qu'elle pouvait s'appuyer pour
aller plus haut ainsi avec eux ce
contexte va la fin de l'année et jacky a
été très mauvaise note en mathématiques
seriez dans les zones matière encore
mais catastrophe en mathématiques ainsi
le corps enseignant lui demanda de
chercher à une formation et jacques
obtint l'insa lyon était d'accord pour
partie a été heureux de commencer loin
des problèmes mais il y à là légaux à
genoux en effet ils avaient perdu
confiance en lui trop de problèmes
il savait plus s'il était fait pour être
ingénieur finalement est ce père qui
lui dit tu as intérêt à réussir cette
année selon j ai plus tes études
d'ailleurs mon fils je sais pas c'était
fait pour être ingénieur vu comment tu
penses c'est étrange alors jacky à la
avec peu de confiance en lui et bien sûr
mais bon puis il passera le la première
année à l'insa lyon il ya eu 6 et un
deuxième année il y avait des très
bonnes choses mais pas assez pour lui
alors il se dit que c'est peut-être
l'émotion finalement l'émotionnel qui
était en cause dans l'histoire alors il
alla je sais que thérapeute là bas et
puis déposer les armes et il découvrit
que finalement ils sont il ne ressentait
plus la peur plus l'amour plus le stress
et ça a été tué cette carapace qui
s'était fâché tout au long de ces années
pour se protéger et publié à l'est puis
c'est notre augmenter jusqu'au point où
à fin de l'année et obtenu et obtint
line salsa génie civil le département
des génies s'il y va à nice alyssa de
lyon voilà un projet de cinq ans
réalisée je m'appelle enzo somme ça et
maximilien jacques faisons y va bien
compris jacques hémond 4ème prénom ceci
mon histoire je vous la raconte
parce que pour vous montrer que c'est
impossible et votre et mentale en effet
pourquoi se définir définir à
l'impossible est impossible frontières
mais c'est pas qu'ils aient réseau je
sais qu'il a des qualités et qu'il a
certaines valeurs je ne sais pas ce qui
peut vraiment faire essayer de se
définir en soit défini une frontière
et comme je vais dis donc impossible et
impôts c'est impossible
en effet en effet c'est un [ __ ] de
trous là
je vais cela va être dur et c'est un
joker de se battre mais qu'elle mérite à
retenir quelque chose de simple pour moi
il y aura qu aucun même temps essayer
d'être votre propre ami ils vont avoir
des gens qui vont essayer vous freinez
vous catégoriser vous juger et faire de
vous ce que veulent mais c'est à vous
d'imposer vos rêves
il y parvenir en effet vous me vivre ses
rêves créer sa vie à se l'arracher gérer
des efforts la motivation beaucoup de
recul mais surtout de l'échec il faut
pas avoir peur d'échouer c'était chat
qui a été normalisé où on dire tu t'es
trompé assez teigneux ce que tu as fait
c'est pas bien non selon moi et mon
expérience
soit l'on gagne soit on apprend et
l'échec et la mer des leçons en effet
vous a marqué et cette leçon restera
tout le temps je finirai ce discours
avec un conseil qui me suis tout de ma
vie et et dont j'ai fait ma devise
aidez vous même le salon est dehors
merci
[Applaudissements]